by the way uh when you when you were in
hangover it's a bad and i know people
are gonna be like shitty walking [ __ ]
off i wasn't even trying yeah it was a
great walk-in
but did you guys party out on when you
went hangover was it just kind of like
work was it purely work all work nobody
knew that movie was gonna be a big deal
you're joking bradley i'd known bradley
and zach galifianakis and all those guys
nobody knew the movie was going to be no
but i'd known bradley cooper for five
years before that i knew zac alphonax
for 10 years before that it was a little
movie uh you know i was asked to come in
and you know uh i knew todd phillips the
director and the guy was supposed to be
from new york talking like this you know
you don't remember me i'm eddie you know
how could you not remember you know
he was all oh yeah he's from the bronx
in new york and i was the one that i
said look dude if the dude and i even
said this because you'll appreciate this
i said if he's in vegas and he owns a
wedding chapel he should be from armenia
or lebanon or something like that you
know i can get you anything you want my
friend what do you boards it's a bit
whatever you need my friend i can get
you wine
so he he loved that and that was how it
happened but when we did the movie bro
it was like
you know
i mean i tell the story you know it's
it's so funny because
bradley and i were walking through i
think caesar's palace and a group of
tourists
wanted to take a picture with the guy
from mad tv
what do you want to know who held the
camera and took the picture right now
wow blue eyes nobody knew him
why it wasn't well he was sack lodge and
wedding christmas i remember when
limitless was the movie they were
watching and see if he could pull it off
and he did that was a great movie that
was a sick movie sick but that guy nzt
yeah but he was all he loves acting
bradley
i just saw because of ray leota you
mentioned it i watched goodfellas last
night probably i'm not joking for the
50th time and while i was in the gym
today there's a documentary where with
scorsese and the writing with nick
bellagio yeah everything and then uh
henry hill he uh the real henry hill he
was in witness protection he couldn't
come on the set but he would uh rob de
niro would call him in the morning five
six times and go hey how did this guy
hold the cigarette how they talked how
did he pour the ketchup how do he bro i
get goosebumps right now and then god
rest his soul dude
that ever since i was a kid i wanted to
be a gangster so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you